overcrowded pool parties and beaches
sparking some outrage on social media
this weekend in missouri health
officials are ripping local leaders
for allowing those massive crowds like
these at the lake of the ozarks one
missouri
mayor says people not taking precautions
will have to police themselves
this is not the kind of image that i
think we want to be projecting
at least from a pandemic
guideline enforcement standpoint but
when i say again
you know enforcement you know that that
that's a that's a that's a two-edged
sword
it is the responsibility i believe
of our guests who are down here who come
down here
let's bring in our fox news contributor
dr mark siegel professor of medicine at
nyu langone doctor good morning
morning ed how are you fantastic what
that mayor is saying something i've
heard you say before is that we
essentially have to treat
adults like adults but when you see some
of these pictures when adults are not
behaving well
essentially and not social distancing
how concerned are you
about places like the ozarks and others
where we've seen this play out
i'm very disturbed about this ed those
pictures from over the weekend
uh in missouri lake of the ozarks is
about is driving distance from st
louis and kansas city then you had
florida
several different areas of florida tampa
had a parking lot to be closed
because there were so many people
milling around the east coast of florida
galveston texas all three of the states
i mentioned have flattened the curve
but if you see this kind of cavorting
going on you know there's a lot of
asymptomatic spread of covet 19. we
don't exactly know how it spreads
but close contact is definitely going to
spread it now
dr deborah burks of the task force said
you know if you're going to be close
together at least wear a mask
i would with all due respect tend to
disagree with that slightly
because i don't think the mask does
nearly as much as the social distancing
does
and it's several feet that a cough or a
sneeze can travel here
and we're going to end up having a
problem as we reopen if people
are congregating like this i'm deeply
disturbed about this missouri is saying
some of the officials are saying that
maybe these people should go into
quarantine after this kind of behavior
and i'm not against that we have to do
something
and just as the summer is is starting is
sort of the unofficial
start of summer of course memorial day
weekend uh people are going to have to
listen to good advice from you
uh no doubt about it i want to get to
something else that's more optimistic
which is
we're all waiting on a vaccine now we
have this new company
nova vaxx they have a trial there's some
positive news that's part of
the reason why the dow is popping this
morning phase one begins in australia
with 130 participants
between the ages of 18 to 59. trial will
test two dosages
both with and without a vaccine first
results expected in july
if successful phase two would include
u.s
and other countries walk us through
where you see some good things here and
where you may have concerns
i'm actually very very excited about
this this is the 10th candidate
that's going to be entering clinical
trials and here's what's interesting
and dr fauci called this shots on goal
right
they're all different ed this particular
vaccine is using
insects yet to grow the proteins that
are like the virus
to provoke your immune system we've
talked about moderna and the pfizer
vaccines using genetic technology
that's never been used in a vaccine
before to study your cells with those
proteins
that cause the immune response the one
out of oxford university uses a little
older technology
the newer ones may actually provoke more
of a robust response but
one thing's for sure with all of these
different vaccine candidates
proceeding so rapidly into clinical
trials
i am optimistic with the manufacturing
being set up to
keep pace with this to keep pace with
the science that we may end up with a
vaccine
by the er by the end of this year or
early next year it's really really
looking good right now
never been done this way all right we're
going to be watching it very closely dr
siegel appreciate your advice as always
thank you